le ministre de l'intérieur suggère une
réforme de la législation en matière de
délinquance juvénile une proposition de
loi de l'opposition visant à modifier
l'ordonnancé de 1945 sur la délinquance
des mineurs
le gouvernement veut réformer
l'ordonnancé de 1945 elle est dans le
collimateur de certains gouvernements
depuis des décennies à son instauration
l' ordonnance de 1945 qui encadrent
encore aujourd'hui la délinquance des
mineurs avaient pour objectif d'éduquer
des jeunes délinquants
plutôt que les punir les portes ne
mènera plus à des prisons le bal d'antan
est mort qu'on à saint maurice dans ce
centre qui pourra servir d'exemple aux
autres on ne parle plus de châtiment
mais de rééducation mais dans les années
90 à la suite des émeutes dans les
banlieues françaises
cette philosophie est jugée trop laxiste
par la droite
c'est le début des modifications le
garde des sceaux jacques toubon sous la
présidence de jacques chirac
on entame alors des réformes pour durcir
la justice des mineurs
le garde des sceaux veut une justice
rapide pour les mineurs une comparution
à délai rapproché d'un à quatre mois
maximum
objectif de la chancellerie gommer le
sentiment d'impunité qui favorise la
récidive en 2002 toujours sous la
présidence de jacques chirac
l'ordonnancé de 1945 continue de se
durcir
le ministre de la justice dominique
perben propose entre autres
l'instauration de centres éducatifs
fermés ou encore la possibilité de
placer un mineur en détention provisoire
dès l'âge de 13 ans il faut la foi la
prévention et la sanction la sanction
faisant d'ailleurs partie de l'acte
éducatif
plus répressifs aussi nicolas sarkozy en
2006 il apportait d'autres modifications
au texte de 1945
cette ordonnance a vieillit parce qu'un
mineur de 1945 n'a rien à voir avec un
mineur de 2006 en 2008 cette fois en
tant que président de la république
nicolas sarkozy fait de la délinquance
des mineurs son cheval de bataille
avec toujours en ligne de mire l'
ordonnance de 1945 il compte alors sur
sa garde des sceaux rachida dati pour en
finir une bonne fois pour toutes avec ce
texte un texte qui a perdu de sa
pertinence
est ce un texte qui a parfois perdu de
son efficacité la société de 1945 n'a
absolument rien à voir avec la société
en 70 ans l'ordonnancé de 1945 a été
modifié une cinquantaine de fois
s'éloignant toujours un peu plus de sa
volonté originelle de l'éducation plutôt
que de la répression
une réalité illustrée par ces chiffres
en 1994 le taux de réponse pénale dans
les affaires impliquant des mineurs
était de 60 % en 2013 ils étaient 2 94%
[Musique]